The 2013 HKTDC Hong Kong Book Fair...
...welcomed a record-breaking 560 exhibitors from 30 countries and regions.
Under the theme "Reading the World - Reading for a Better World,"...
...this year's fair featured more than 400 cultural events and 300 speakers,...
...including several acclaimed authors.
Other highlights of the HKTDC Hong Kong Book Fair include the 50th anniversary exhibition...
...of the Chinese literary character, Wisely, featuring the manuscripts, book covers...
...and other memorabilia of its creator, Hong Kong writer Ni Kuang.
Catering to tech-savvy readers, e-book vending machines debuted at the 2013 fair.
Using smart card payment, readers simply scan the QR codes to download the book.
Free downloads of more than 160 e-books were on offer.
But the ultimate high-tech treat was this 3D exhibition of the Mogao Caves in Dunhuang.
The animated 3D exhibition featured a 360-degree panoramic projection theater.
Using virtual reality technology, the exhibition offered a close-up look...
...at 1,000-year-old Buddhist wall paintings...
...at the World Heritage Site in northwest China.